Unbelievable.
Historically movies and TV shows have had a problem showing what coding and
hacking is actually like. I think, you know what I'm talking about, I'm trying,
it's moving too fast.
Many filmmakers used to not bother making their scenes accurate.
They went with their own idea of hacking that looks exciting and feels intense.
They were probably afraid that if they went, realistically,
they'd end up with something like this.
So I go through these thousands of lines of code and, uh,
it doesn't really matter.
So with a few exceptions hacking in the nineties and two thousands is either
highly exaggerated or incomprehensible. It's honestly,
I don't blame the filmmakers for making this choice.
Watching someone sit at a computer is boring.
And the vast majority of movie goers didn't have a clue how hacking works.
Most of them probably didn't care how it worked anyway,
but in the last 10 years or so,
there's been a big shift in how movies and TV portray hacking.
Maybe it's because the public better understands how technology works,
or maybe it's because people want more realistic storytelling, whatever it is.
Modern shows like Mr. Robot now have extremely accurate hacking scenes and even
comedies like Silicon Valley puts some effort. In fact,
checking the technology they're making fun of,
but even with all this new technical accuracy,
there's still a bit of deception going on.
Filmmakers still make hacking out to always be this incredibly complicated
process that requires a technical genius.
You made it really hard for anyone to see it, but I saw it.
Reality. A lot of the hacking you see on the big screen is surprisingly easy.
Sometimes it's so simple. You don't even need experience to understand it.
All you need is an internet connection and a basic understanding of a few
vulnerabilities to prove my point.
Let's analyze the sequence from the social network and see if you can do some
hacking yourself. Let the hacking begin
in this scene.
Mark Zuckerberg hacks into websites on the Harvard network and steals pictures
of female students for his face mash app. Not only is this scene realistic,
but it's hacking that Mark Zuckerberg actually did in 2003.
He documented his techniques in an online journal.
And some of the dialogue in the movie is taken word for word from it.
They keep everything open and allow indexes in their Apache configuration.
So little w you get magic as all that's necessary to download the entire
Kirkland,
Facebook kids stuff based on how he delivers this line and how quickly the
moment flies by the average movie.
Goer might think that this hacking is only kid stuff for a genius like Mark
Zuckerberg, even screenwriter, Aaron Sorkin felt this way.
With her scenes in the social network. Honestly,
I don't understand when he's telling us how he's hacking into things,
that's acquired knowledge, it's phonetic knowledge.
But this is probably the easiest hacking out there that I promise you can do.
And I'll prove it to you go to Jack
mnuchin.io/youtube mash in your favorite browser.
It's a website built like Mark Zuckerberg space match site,
except instead of comparing girls at Harvard, you can judge all of now.
You see it's past videos,
go to the logo in the top left corner and view the image.
Every browser lets you do this,
but the option just has a slightly different name.
Once you're at the page with the image,
you just need to remove the name of the image from the URL.
And you get a list of all the thumbnails from every now you see a video and
there you have it. You're a hacker like Mark Zuckerberg. That's all that he did.
It's true that he was clever enough to check if this website had this
configuration and he also knew about w get a package that lets you download all
the images on a webpage, but this really is kid stuff.
You don't need to be a hacking expert to check if an images location,
isn't a website's public directory.
If you tried this technique on other websites,
it's probably not going to work because most websites have tightened their
security. Since 2003,
even this website is just faking it as if this video is published.
Date apache.org/icons, still indexes images,
the exact same way that sucker Burk exploited.
If you want to see a patchy indexing in the wild.
Excellent moving right along.
Later in the scene,
the market needs to quickly get a large stash of photos for face match.
So he writes some code.
To do at a time.
And there's no way I'm going to go to 500 pages to download picks one at a time.
So it's definitely necessary to break out Emacs and modify that Perl script.
He solving a simple problem.
It would take too long to manually go through every page and download the
thumbnails. Instead he writes a few lines of code that repeat the process.
We just went through for every page on the site. Not so complicated.
If you think about it,
if you want it to do this on the Jack nugent.io/youtube mash site,
the random video button gives you a random thumbnail.
You could go through all the URLs for each video and do the same thing he did.
I'm doing it with slightly different code, but it's still the same idea.
And now that you've got all the images, it's time to make Facemash.
The algorithm.
Support algorithm is usually abused in movies to make something instantly sounds
Epic.
I did was come up with my own kick algorithms.
But an algorithm is simply a step-by-step solution to any problem.
It's an equation it's code, or it's even a recipe for making food.
The algorithm for Facemash is copying what chess players use to calculate their
ratings.
Let's say the matrix a different perspective has a rating of 1600 and why jump
scares. SOC has a rating 1200.
The score just tells us the likelihood that a video will win in any given
matchup. The higher a videos ELO.
The more likely it is to win because the matrix video has a higher rating.
It's expected to win 90% of the time.
And the jump scares video it's expected to win 10% of the time,
depending on who wins. Another algorithm adjusts, each video score.
If a video wins that isn't expected to win the algorithm adjusted score more
drastically because the video's current score is apparently too low.
Each video starts with a rating of 1400 and the algorithm takes it from there.
These equations are the exact same way.
Chess players get their ELO scores and it's the same way.
Mark Zuckerberg ranked women on their attractiveness.
And now I'm using the same algorithm to find out what you really think of. Now.
You see it videos.
The social network is an example of the current trends to make hacking and
movies and TV more accurate. But at first glance,
the movie still portrays having as incredibly complicated.
It only feels that way because they make the dialogue really fast and throw in
software jargon like Apache w get an email.
And then all of a sudden it feels like you have to be a genius to understand it,
but you can do that with anything related to technology.
I can do the same thing with my YouTube mash website, spin up a static site,
easy.
I'll just create an S3 bucket underneath the CDN surface with SSL encryption.
Then all I have to do is pages Gatsby for Lightspeed performance and automate
deployment with the [inaudible] algorithm, kids stuff.
All that is just a fancier way of saying I made a website.
Of course not all hacking is as easy as what they did in the social network,
but filmmakers don't seem to differentiate the simple from the difficult.
So the next time you see an insane hacking scene, that makes no sense to you.
Don't forget that you can still hack like Mark Zuckerberg.
Welcome to Facebook. [inaudible].
Keegan movies and TV has become more realistic.
At least partially due to an increasing computer literacy.
The average person knows more about computers than ever before.
And our entertainment reflects that it's never been easier to learn how to build
a website or exploit the faults in what you can learn,
how to make websites using YouTube stack overflow,
or there's a great tutorial by Christopher Todd called understanding web
development.
It's an incredibly explained to introduction to the basics of making your own
website from scratch. If you want to check out this video,
you can view it on Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community that can help you learn and grow.
Even with a busy schedule classes,
cover every topic from film production to coding.
So if you're interested in diving deeper into what I discussed today,
it's the perfect resource to get started.
So now that you know how to hack like Mark Zuckerberg,
you can learn how to code like him too, but don't worry.
You don't have to afford a Harvard education to get there.
An annual subscription is less than $10 a month.
And the first 500 of my subscribers that click the link in the description,
we'll get a two month free trial of premium membership.
So you can explore your creativity. Plus it helps us out too.
Thank you guys so much for watching and getting this far in the video.
I thought of the idea for this video over the summer,
but I put it on the back burner because I was worried.
It didn't really fit the style of the channel.
I was able to make the video I wanted to make because you guys were there
supporting the channel the whole time. We want it to make an interesting,
weird video.
And if you guys also think it was interesting and you want to see more videos
like this, then support us on Patriot. There,
you can get early access to videos,
shout outs in the credits and to behind the scenes, look at our script process.
So support us on Patrion or let me know on Twitter or YouTube,
if you liked this kind of video and hopefully we can make more of them. Thanks.